today we're doing a cookie episode yes
cookies got to start things off right
get some cookie gravy
aka milk I may be slightly like us
intolerant not cookie intolerant right
no no rink milk to that okay I can't
hide this anymore
Adam messed up and instead of milk we
have drinkable yogurt it's so thick
today I'm worth it what are we trying
three cookies at three drats with a
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
nice what is the best time that he to
Kobe cookies are really in any time
fruit I would eat a cookie before bed
after bed in the middle of the day so
we're on a way to mazda our bakery
having shortbread cookie well so you
still have milk on your mouth it's
yogurt my name is um Brahma this is
Moses our bakery and today we're trying
our vanilla shortbread where is the name
Mazda dark comes on it's a word in the
order language to describe the magic or
the essence that makes something special
it's what draws you in again and again
and we hope that that's what you find
with our food you fall in love with us
and you come back we were named best
doughnut in New York City by the times
and last year we were put on another New
York Times list of the 10 best foods of
the year so you have all these fantastic
pastries I wonder why is it important to
still have that shortbread at a dollar
we don't want anyone to come into the
bakery in thing that they can't afford
to be here there's certain things that
cost a lot more money and i spite size
indulgences and that's an apprentice
does it come in a couple different
flavors or it does spider pecan and we
also do a chocolate saw blade and what
are those defining flavors or essence of
shortbread it kind of shatters a little
bit which is really fun the most
important thing you can't hide behind
sure friend it is what it is totally
naked so we start with the highest
quality ingredients high fat butter
unbleached flour Madagascar vanilla Erin
Kennedy vows is our executive pastry
chef and she's going to be working with
me today to make the shortbread once
we've made the dough we run it through a
sheeter and we punch the cookies out
sprinkle sugar on them and then we put
them in a 325-degree convection oven we
tend to under bake them and then watch
the last couple of minutes Mozza their
bakery was born of my love of food as a
child my family traveled all over the
world we'd be in Sweden and we'd have
bread for breakfast and we'd have to
close our eyes my mom would say
what you taste it would have saffron in
it it's like ah this tastes like the
rice and Spain food became a way to
connect people through flavors and
experiences do you still cover your eyes
and eat food or I do I don't cover my
eyes in restaurants what my team tells
me often that when I'm tasting something
I'll close my eyes we can do that close
our eyes adjacent yes won't you Cheers
oh man it smells like bugger he out like
butter Cheers Oh hmm I can taste the
butter very present a slight hint of
vanilla it is the perfect drink
accompaniment cookie yes I'm just nibble
away not worried about getting crumbs on
yourself oh I got a lot of times with
myself though do we get more AB I have
another yeah I want another one you know
around that's what I'm going back this
is when you get comped at the casino and
they bring over just a tray of chips for
you chocolate Cheers you know with my
eyes closed you know what this tastes
like when you get a little bite of this
still crystallized cocoa powder that's
my Ma's ID our moment when I close my
eyes and eat this cookie just come in
from playing in the snow
my fingers are still numb I'm drinking
my cocoa and at the end of the cup it's
very weird to watch people eat with
their eyes closed really realizing that
now
also the smell of this cookie is a
bakery at work if this was a Cologne I
would be irresistible sure but it will
never be you can eat this cookie in any
outfit like this cookie is perfectly at
home wearing a tuxedo after the Opera or
flip-flops and shorts on the weekend you
could take this cookie to the ball you
can take this cookie to the beach this
is my just woke up at 1:00 a.m. in my
boxers I just want to eat a cookie I
take back the outfit there
you and your boxers eating this cookie
is unacceptable today except for I eat
it sure thank you can I feed you okay
that's for a bread cookie yes
so good it was very good do you think of
it we're getting spoiled today guys
usually sweets before a meal is not the
right way to go but cookies one of those
things where I don't mind making that my
pre-game meal I mean cookie is the
perfect afternoon dessert they're like 4
o'clock cookie is really a thing to
behold so the next cookie is actually
pretty much a meal yes I think it was
invented to be calorific calorific
anyway
it's gonna be a day full of cookies but
these aren't any time foods all right no
big deal hi I'm Connie McDonald's name
is Pam weeks you're at Levin bakery and
you're gonna be trying our world-famous
cookies today
you've known each other for very long
yeah can you tell us about how you met
we were actually training for an Ironman
triathlon and sharing the cookies just
like made it all
it was the cookie and after like right
thing was it in your gym during the bike
ride did you ever take it yeah you know
sustainable and often durable enough
where you could just put it in your bike
shirt and go how many different types of
cookies do you have here chocolate chip
walnut oatmeal raisin a dark chocolate
chocolate and a dark chocolate peanut
butter chips what's the chocolate chip
walnut cookie it's screaming butter and
sugar adding eggs flour salt leavening
semi-sweet chocolate chips and walnuts
it's just like really good ingredients
so to keep things simple and so when you
first bake these cookies what was the
motivation for this style this size
gives us a crunchy outside the gooey
inside this is less about scale and more
about textural effect exactly cuz I've
heard a lot of people say like oh Levin
that's the giant cookie place but no
it's a place where it's the perfect
combination of textures that's nice I
like that t-shirt God is like one in a
child we've gotten every type of cookie
this should be the chocolate chip walnut
check out how far apart my fingers are
can went to the inside oh that's gooey
look how money chocolate chips are in
here this is crazy
yeah I can't talk those my mouth is
still full I need milk yeah you get so
much in one bite crunchy crispy gooey
ooey gooey not you because it's not you
know it's more like movie that's gooey
the walnut really does do something for
the chocolate chip cookie that I wasn't
expecting oh it smells like good
chocolate is that stupid to say no
oh I was expecting it to be too
chocolatey
yeah it's really nice it's very good
when is the best time to eat this levan
cookie I would eat this cookie anytime
anytime yo
lone druid this cocaine I guess you're
right actually tell me a time that you
wouldn't need my cookies I would eat it
right now yeah like you think about it
and now you want it exactly okay now
we'll do the oatmeal it never gets old
how heavy this cookie is no it was like
a good meatball that might be the one
people sneeze at the oatmeal raisin I
think they're sleeping on it you know I
just realized that we've eaten three
cookies and now I need to go do a trial
hunt the most tempting thing when you're
making cookies is to eat cookie dough
you're getting that texture too in the
middle of the cookie I've never really
seen the appeal of raw cookie dough
what's wrong with you I think for the
first time I'm getting that satisfaction
in a way that I find acceptable
worth a cooking fact we're not doing
effect today sorry for this next part
we're gonna be traveling to Japan again
we made it we're right huh
today we're in Tokyo and we brought our
very best friend ray mcclenney hello
Andrew found eight amazing cookie maybe
one of the best in the world so this is
a very unique style of cookie it's
focused on the visuals the artistry and
it's also extremely unique because we're
not going to learn anything about the
person who makes it they would prefer
that we just focus on the cookie itself
without the influence of information
about them I can't wait this is a very
first unworthy I'm so excited
they're not even gonna let us know where
they work what they do it could be a bat
cave it could be a fortress of solitude
no interview but we're gonna now cut to
something
[Music]
would you look at these beautiful
cookies these are the work of aunt opal
icing cookie a custom cookie maker in
Japan so Andrew said you're not gonna
learn anything about the people behind
these cookies and that's true we're not
gonna get an on-camera interview but we
can let you in on a few cookie secrets
the cookie you're looking at now is
about 90 dollars it's a custom design
and it's based on a traditional Japanese
motif shipping cookies obviously
prevents them from getting too fancy
with their designs but luckily since
they're making a custom one for us here
that's going to be devoured immediately
they had the chance to be a little more
ornate with it it takes this one person
hours of painstakingly detailed work to
make this cookie each little layer of
frosting has to dry before they can
apply another one so yeah that's where
the $90 comes from sure plenty of
cookies are cute but aunt Oppo strives
to create elegant cookies in their
process of making iced cookies and Topo
discovered you could use the icing to
create three-dimensional designs and the
ultimate use of that technique is
creating a bird with individual feathers
each with their own depth before we get
to the main feature we're going to have
one of untold' those smaller offerings I
don't believe that there's a cookie in
there this looks like how much jewelry
is sold this reminds me of the packaging
from Lego I can't destroy this Adam
don't make me eat it
you eat it no well that's okay it's fine
it's just a cookie I can't believe I
just did that
[Music]
mmm it's awesome yeah it's not too sweet
I like that a lot can I finish this yeah
[Music]
are you speaking Japanese or English it
pays very nostalgic for me I always like
something my mom made what do you think
that is cookie every time I look at this
I smile when I look at pictures of it I
smile look can we do head for scale real
quick yeah it's not just impressive in
this scale yeah it's like a topographic
map yeah you can see the Rocky Mountain
as it spills out into the Pacific Valley
down here by the legs yeah look at that
can you tell that we're just trying to
avoid yeah I don't want to do it where
do you even start let's start with the
feet 3 2 1
I thought though that doing that I'm
sorry
cheers David Cheers
hmmm very reminiscent of the shortbread
I just won more than the last one Oh God
I know I got that taste in my mouth yeah
we got four you know how you're supposed
to leave a cookie for Santa can you
imagine there's must eat that in couples
house yeah dear when he came down the
chimney he was like this I thought I had
the little elves in my workshop they've
been out making cookies for someone else
honey the tail section no really I want
I want oh it's like a little angels wing
you murderer
this cookie is literally just four
ingredients with icing you have this
elegant design with this very simple
food which is what makes it so great
yeah really with me which is which means
I know I'm saying something right
whether that doesn't want to feel the
texture in right now okay so awesome
yeah feels so nice oh I love this cookie
okay we have something
[Music]
which cookie was the most worth it to
you Andrew 3 I don't think you'd get one
because you only had one of them all
right I agree actually until those my
words of winter really look something
that makes me not want to eat it but
it's also delicious what are the thing
call when you have like your cognitive
business cooking of native dissidents
who to pick who to pick on topo with
feast for the eyes
Levin a feast for my thighs with it
winner mozz a dark it was the best taste
her net weight of any of the cookies we
have and that's the criteria that I'm
going to choose to value the most
because all the cookies were genuinely
so delicious it's the mozz a da right
yeah you know I can't put my finger on
it there you weren't there but mozz Adar
is like the that's not French is there a
Japanese phrase for secret sauce sweet
whistles
Kashia kikuchiyo g kc i see that back ec
i see this it a better okay that again
kikuchiyo gee what a knee goodra with a
winner
wow that's right and finally Adam next
up what are you gonna see Andrew we're
gonna see egg-shaped things fish shape
things box shape things what does that
mean you don't know if you guys rhyme
you could be dr. Seuss
- I would be dr. Zeus cuz that's how
good I would be at rhyming in it see a L
o er I e s we get in Calabrese oh yes